what's going on guys
ride along - is hidden fears once again
ice cube and Kevin Hart are teamed up to
have fun and fight crime
their unlikely partners so screen
junkies decided to team me up with an
unlikely partner my mom I know right to
sit back and ride along with me and my
mom as we interview the cast of
ride-along - in Miami
thanks to screen junkies and ride-along
- I was off to sunny Miami where I met
up with my mom Deborah Rudnick even
though we'd never been to Miami before
there wasn't much time for sightseeing
because it was time to take my mom to
her first big Hollywood premiere are you
nervous that you're not going to be able
to keep up with this movie because you
didn't see the first one no it's pretty
explanatory you know that you can
because it's similar in a way okay I'll
shoot your face is it a lot like
sponsors back to the death weird damn
Castille chop it what's your review of
the movie I review it as saying it's a
good fast moving fun is it a good film
for seniors definitely they never fall
asleep in that one ride-along - it'll
keep you awake even though mom wanted to
party on the beach until the break of
dawn she had to turn in for her beauty
rest because tomorrow was her first
Hollywood junket she was a little
nervous at first but some of the stars
of the film were able to put her at ease
so ride-along was great and you have
such a natural Odd Couple with ice cube
and Kevin Hart yeah and we figured
interview wise we'd put together an odd
couple so my mom is conducting the
interview yeah yeah I love it
thank you I love that I love mom so
you're welcome dr. ken yay yeah ekta
Kent well you are a real doctor right
okay well I have some questions because
I've been taking a blood pressure pill
for a long time
Noah vas norvasc you yeah could that be
why I haven't had any sexual desire in
five years
I mean sometimes any of these
antihypertensive can decreased libido I
I think
medically speaking I don't know you but
as a doctor you look like you have a
healthy libido and I think that if
there's any decrease in said libido it's
only due to the calcium channel norvasc
that you're taking and I would say if
your blood pressure is good at ten
milligrams I will probably take it to
five milligrams so that would probably
decrease the side-effect profile and
then you would have just raw sex appeal
that you normally have Ken that was Wow
you know your stuff um while you're in
me at Miami uh are you gonna do it do it
up big like big Willy star while you're
in Miami you're gonna go out and do it
up big Willy star only if you're coming
dad yeah yeah by the way what is Big
Willy style ah it's a new phrasing on
each I have no idea so you have to
interview Benjamin Bratt are you excited
well if you aren't along I'd be more
excited
did you like that dance scene that he
was in mom yeah did you yeah what do you
yeah what did you like about it mom well
let me tell you when I thought about
please really so you look good oh you're
sweet look at you - thank you pretty
damn good gonna have a lot of women
chasing you go oh mama that's so your
mom is one oh yeah you know gives you
those feelings mom I didn't bring you
here to sexually harass Benjamin Bratt
Benjamin at the bar for sugar mommy or
what uh I'm starting to spits a little
bit mom
maybe that's our time to say thank you
mr. Bratt that interview with Benjamin
Bratt was enough to give my mom a real
thrill but there was still one last
interview and it was the biggest of them
all the stars of the film ice cube and
Kevin Hart
first of all gentlemen congratulations
on a super funny action-packed movie
thank you so much
what when I told you you're gonna
interview ice cube and Kevin Hart what
did you say
Oh ice cube I I love his reality show
and I love cocoa in the Bulldog is just
great and mom who did you realize you
were talking about
ice-t right but do you like Ice Cube now
o sweetest thank you so wonderful God
innocent mistake did we're not home yet
home yet finish Jeff yes that one very
good
and I Kevin I have a question for you ha
ha ha ha ha ha my hairdresser Frank said
to me when if you see Kevin Hart would
you ask him how does he get his teeth so
white what toothpaste does he use that's
a real question he wanted to know I'll
be honest with you it's not just one
because I travel so much I'm big on
Colgate though because those commercials
tricked me mainly Colgate yeah tell
Frank a second yeah and Ice Cube
famously you had a Tsonga the police now
you play a policeman in this story what
why the change
oh my mom my mom wash my mouth out with
soap and it uh made me a new man
Oh spank my bottom huh they sent me back
out there telling me to be nice and
while you're in Miami yeah
why you gentlemen gonna go out and
do it up Big Willie style Big Willie
style
he's the stripclub King we got it I mean
he has glitter on get off don't she
don't need to know my personal business
out here we're both getting a little
older so it's not it's not at the the
pace that we used to do it but we love
to go out we do a medium Lily stand on
me like medium really style you're more
than welcome when gentlemen you guys are
great sports and thank you for making an
awesome movie and talk about okay she
did it
my mom had finished her first Hollywood
junket and made some of the funniest
actors in the business laughs
hysterically and I couldn't be more
proud today you were the star and I love
you make me the star you're great
producer
one day to go hey hey I'll take it I'll
take it but thank you mom for you in the
star unless I have the direction good
job get that make someone look into the
camera that's a bye bye bye bye bye bye
love you guys
hi well that was a good time I want to
thank everyone was ride along too for
being such good sports please go check
it out in theaters starting Friday
January 15 now let me ask you guys what
would you want to interview with your
mom let us know in the comments section
below the best answer um we're gonna
send you screen junkies t-shirts I want
to thank you for watching I'm al redneck
hit me up on Twitter bye bye I'm taking
django Django Unchained it is it was a
more important movie into overtones of
slavery and and revenge and all these
other aspects that were going on to that
film I think Django and chained gets the
nod from it bingo bango bango Marc Ellis
is going Django